[Music]
shenan escu thank you for joining me H
startup Nation United we're about three
and a half weeks into the war now since
um the terrible October 7th um been
extremely inspired by um by the
incredible initiatives and projects that
have emerged from the ecosystem some
technological some social some um
internal organ ganizational and so I'm
really looking forward to hearing your
your journey and the impact you've had
over the last three and a half weeks so
so thank you again for being here um I
I'd like to start even before we dive
into the word itself tell me a little
bit about you know what what who you are
and and what do you do in the in the
day-to-day outside of the context of of
what's Happening
Now yeah it's uh you know it's usually
an easy question that we're used to
answering so quickly what you know we
have our pitch but the past few weeks
three weeks have been uh you know making
me take the time to remember what it is
that I do uh but I am a climate Tech
investor I invest directly into early
stage uh climatech companies uh and
funds and also I'm the co-founder and
chair of Planet Tech uh which is a
nonprofit that aims to divert the
Israeli climate Tech scene into solving
one of the world's uh largest crisis and
actually now when I speak to you you
know I'm always asked why I believe so
much in the Israeli climatic ecosystem
and I always say it's because we're so
good at emergency and so good at crisis
so why don't we just solve you know such
a huge crisis and I'm used to talking
about that uh and I never in my life I I
would imagine that uh this will be
fulfilled in the shape of the entire
country and the entire Tech ecosystem is
joining forces in so many inspiring
initiatives like you said that I'm also
in a of uh that we've seen in the past
three
weeks 100% completely agree um where
were you on October 7th um 6:30 a.m.
when when the events
transpired uh honestly I was asleep I
thought it was a thunderstorm I told you
I'm I'm obsessed with climate like it
overl to me to like stuff like that
um I woke up in my Tel Aviv apartment on
a usual Saturday to so many messages
asking me if I'm okay and I'm like okay
whatever something happens one of the
usual things that we unfortunately got
used to and I was like um I made coffee
and I sat down and I really remember
this moment when I'm like starting to
realize what is happening uh very
intuitively I just packed a bag and
start started to to find ways to maybe
go up north to my family and just
immediately went into this kind of like
survival mode because we didn't really
know what was going on uh I knew about
the party I know I knew sorts of details
but I wasn't really sure what is
happening but it did feel already then
like a pivotal moment and I don't know
if it I I didn't know how much I guess
like like most people
right no it was definitely a it was an
accruing understanding that that all of
us had over what the significance of the
of of that um moment and
day so obviously as an entrepreneur you
you you yourself spring into action and
I was wasn't surprised to hear that um
tell me how things transpired so what
was the process in which you then
adjusted to taking action what you've
done who you did it with all
that yeah so honestly for the first few
days I think like many people I was
involved with trying to get vests to
soldiers it's like yeah I got into that
trying to help uh people get whatever
they need um I I realized then that
there are a lot of entities that are
doing that and I wasn't sure it's my
role to be honest I help help a little
bit but I mean I was such in like action
mode that I did so many things at once
and helped fundraising to a bunch of
other initiatives as well which I still
happily support um and then I think it
was maybe one week into this whole uh
chaos we'll call it like that haven't
found the word yet uh that uh my good
friend m Michelle ler um called me and
told me about uh the Israeli F the
Israeli children fund initiative uh
she's a um CEO of Tweed a startup um
there was already a group of a few
amazing people Founders and CEOs like to
from Lo Loi uh Ido from Zen City H Tom
from verbit uh udas like so many amazing
people already there uh so I joined the
team I guess there were 10 people
already um and ever since we actually to
50 people so unfortunately I don't have
the time to mention everyone but it's
really important for me to mention that
each person is like wow an incredible
human being both on a personal level and
a professional level obviously these are
uh people who founded and are currently
managing um Israel's largest most
successful uh tech companies and we also
have investors um like myself like AAL
from pitango uh and many other um
industry and Executives and leaders uh
that you can read all about them um on
our website and it's a I have to tell
you it's a really H special motion and
notion to be a part of this group
because it really does work like a
startup but in a very very um fast
growth rate you know you can imagine
like there's no company that will grow
so quickly right the investors will not
it probably um but everyone is like a
ninja like everyone is capable of doing
so many things so it's been moving
pretty quickly and it really touched me
uh when m Michelle told me about it
because I realized slowly like everyone
the multitude of the horrors that happen
on October 7th yes we still need to
provide everything to the to to the
soldiers to the communities in the South
and the North of Israel
but I think all of us slowly started
realizing there's a
societal
economical
psychological everything right it's a
multifaceted issue issue is a small word
I I don't know how to call it but the it
it it's a huge thing and there's so many
things we need to attend to and
something about the story is that I
started hearing about children who were
left without their parents either their
parents one or both their parents were
taking Hostage to Gaza which is
something that is still unbelievable for
me to to to get out of my mouth even or
uh children who literally SE their
parents slaughtered tortured sometimes
went to really de still are in a really
deep trauma and and and now lost one or
both of their parents um you know we we
hear it in the news there is one story
about a mother that was murdered in
front of her children one is uh four
months old the other is seven years old
the father survived the children were
kidnapped with their neighbor to the ga
to Gaza last minute there was a miracle
I can't explain it and they came back so
of course the they have their father but
now you know their the income of the
household is down the mother worked in a
tech company the father is in
agriculture and Hamas burned the entire
Orchards so they need to pay the bills
they need temporary apartment they need
all this basic stuff now Israel and
other entities um have you know people
are taking care of it but the
bureaucracy takes a lot of time until
the children and the families that are
taking care of them um will be able to
provide all of that and we need it now
um so I was really touched by all the
story obviously how can you not uh and
this is why I I joined just really
simple and we we want to help the
children and their families not just in
the short term and not just to make them
you know survive life we want to make
sure that in the short ter term they get
everything they need their families get
everything they need in order to take
care of them but also we want to make
sure that these children fulfill their
full full potential
you know what I'm saying it's not just
okay let's just make sure you're fine no
they they we need so much and we want to
give them that so we're
not for so long right it's for for years
it's not it's not a what you talking
about is not just an immediate need of
okay can we have them safe now but how
can we support them in the years to come
because this is now going to be with
them for the rest of their life so
exactly and we want them to have great
life we want them to have exceptional
life despite of the strategy and this is
why we have the longer term part of the
program uh which is endowment funds for
the children to make sure they get the
extra so yes the country and the
government may be providing them for
example higher education but we want
them to be able to go to private schools
and we want them to be able to go abroad
and we want them to have a b Mitzvah uh
um you know grants and and we want to
wrap them with everything and also we
want to make sure we utilize our
networks like we love doing in the tech
world and have the tech scene and
Industry have another you know wrap them
with another layer again we're not
trying to replace authorities we're not
trying to replace their families yet
forbid no we just want to give them all
the extra care that they need and just
make sure they're not falling between
the cracks of bureaucracy basically yeah
well well and it's more than that
because I think that you know there
there's a role that governments can play
um in in in the way that you provide
sort of basic necessities and human
rights of course and sustainability for
for people to live and to have you know
hopefully free expression both in terms
of
their terms of the fundamental aspects
of what it means to be human food Water
Shelter in but but in this case it's
much more than that we're talking about
an An Occurrence and an event that is
going to leave them with with with needs
that
perhaps very few governments can
actually attain to so I think that it's
remarkable how you're how you and and
the rest of the 50 amazing people you've
mentioned many of them are very good
friends how you've taken action into
your own hands to to make this impact
tell me a little bit um about what what
you've done over the last 3 weeks um in
in formulating this Israel's CH
Children's Fund uh what has been the
impact so far and um yeah just a bit
about what's been happening
here yeah so um we're obviously
fundraising right now um for the short
term and for the long term it's One Fund
that's raising hundred million um we
already supported um for the shortterm
um eight families and we're in touch
with about 40 which are in total 75
children and unfortunately there are
more uh and we're trying to get to
everyone uh with the most um you know
sensitivity um which we're also learning
I want to be honest with you we're all
tech people each is coming from a
different sector this is new for us and
like we're you know seeing a problem and
try to solve it then this is what we do
so we have started uh very gently uh and
understanding what they need so we
already were luckily able to support
them we already um have some funds that
will allow us to support all the tens of
families that we're in touch of there's
not even a a specific number that I can
tell you right now of how many children
we're talking about because we're still
in this chaotic uh State um as you can
imagine as a country there are no formal
numbers but we're doing the work and we
want to get to every family that is now
taking care of an orphan um child and
just make sure they get the the most
pressing help that they need now and the
best life that they can have and we
believe that we can support them in
having moving from now
on it's a remarkable and so and what I
think is one of the most remarkable
things that we we've talked about in
this um in this uh conversation it's not
just the um the the what you're doing
but but also what you said about how you
know this around the sensitivity you're
saying you know we we're a bunch of tech
people we're not from this you know this
is not what we do in the day-to-day
we're learning but um at the same time
you're learning by engaging and by
impacting perhaps some of the most
sensitive situation that that I could
think of and so I think that it's just a
pretty inspiring thought to have you
know a group of people that in the
day-to-day are you know engineers and
CEOs and investors and and you know
overall great people very smart people
but what but not taking care of children
who've been through tragedies like what
there is now but but regard but that
doesn't mean that you know you're
bystanders you're you're springing into
action you're engaging communicating
fundraising and and and creating an
environment in which you're you're set
to make an impact in you're doing that
um as entrepreneurs and I think that
that's just a a really really
amazing message um for everybody to hear
and and I think that's exactly why I
started this miniseries and because this
is really what what what the I think the
unification of startup nation is all
about and all everybody coming together
so Shen I really want to thank you for
spending this time with me and I wishing
you all the best H with with this with
this super important initiative and it's
not just like you mentioned it's not
just to give them you know to bring them
up to to have a normal life but it's to
enable them to have exceptional lives
and regardless of we hope
so yes thank you very very much thank
you so much than thank
[Laughter]
you